I've made a big mistake you guys beat me
we're supposed to omen because the time
line change in the future what happens
to me hey everybody its charlie we got
all kinds of plot teasers for the flash
arrow three-way crossover that's
happening this year we found out that
they cast the monitor from crisis on
Infinite Earths they announced that the
title is going to be Elseworlds which
invokes a lot of comic book Easter eggs
so I'll try to explain what's going on
with that because they did explain
what's in continuity and what was going
on with the different versions of the
characters there's a new round of that
DC streaming service giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this so
big thing first the official title is
Elseworlds
if you don't know what that is
Elseworlds is a way that DC Comics uses
to describe stories that don't exist in
main continuity it's probably the best
example of that recently is Gotham by
Gaslight which is Batman back during the
time of Jack the Ripper all the
characters are different so obviously
the main version of Batman never existed
during that time period but somebody had
a really awesome pitch for a cool story
so the like okay why don't we just say
that this isn't part of the main
continuity so they did that with a whole
bunch of different stories like Superman
red Sun what would happen if Superman
landed in the Soviet Union instead of
landing in Kansas they grouped those
together and just call them Elseworlds
so when you say Elseworlds usually that
means that it's not the main versions of
the characters so when they announced
that that was the title of this year's
crossover immediately everybody was
asking the producers does this mean that
it's not going to be the main versions
of the characters and it's just gonna be
off by itself outside of the arrowverse
continuity in mark Dugan hi and claimed
that it was not so what they might be
doing is just blending some of our
characters from earth 1 and supergirls
earth obviously with characters from
other worlds so in last year's crossover
it was a multiverse crossover we have
the Nazis coming to our earth it largely
took place on our earth we had a little
bit on theirs because this year it's all
about introducing the bat woman in the
main villain is someone from Arkham
Asylum doing really dangerous stuff that
I'll explain in a second some of our
characters might be spending most of the
time on that other bat woman
whatever they designate that but it
seemingly confirms that she's gonna be
from an alternate universe just like
Supergirl is so Elseworlds the title
isn't so much to describe the continuity
it's more to describe the other worlds
and the stories that are happening there
unfolding while our people are doing
different things on earth one the main
villain this year is going to be dr.
destiny from the comics played by Jeremy
Davies who is also on Constantine I know
a lot of questions about that because
the legends won't be a part of this
year's crossover so it would be kind of
funny though haven't I seen you from
that TV show on NBC that we used to be
on a long time ago
the official plot synopsis for his
character is he's a doctor from Arkham
Asylum for the criminally insane in
Gotham City but he might just be crazier
than the inmates he treats his
machination 'he's will draw a green
arrow flash and Supergirl to Gotham City
so that doesn't really explain why they
would cast the monitor and you know do a
larger multiverse story if he's just
gonna be a crazy person from Arkham
Asylum but I think the sheer fact that
they cast the monitor and he's going to
be a character they actually cast this
actor his name's Lamonica Garrett maybe
you know from designated survivor or
some other big Network shows what
happened is when they introduced the
monitor in the comics is that they
actually just teased him on the lead up
to crisis on Infinite Earths we all know
about the flash future newspaper flash
vanishes in crisis with a 2024 april
date which is basically the flash season
tens finale in real life Grant Gustin
the producers have joked that that might
be their crisis on Infinite Earths like
yeah maybe we'll get to ten seasons like
they never knew if that would actually
be a reality for them what they might be
doing with the monitor in this year's
crossover is just implying that we'll
eventually build up to that moment in a
future year's crossover but I don't
think that they would do that right away
you know like multiverse anti-monitor
it's just way too big to go straight
there and they apply the dis years
crossover was meant to be less crazy
than last year's which is why the
legends aren't a part of it so they
might just be doing the comic book thing
where you know in the lead up Marv
Wolfman would just cameo the monitor in
the background of everyone's comic books
like Teen Titans Justice League Superman
and he would just sit in his space
satellite watching the heroes do
whatever their adventure was that week
so when they actually got to crisis on
Infinite
he gathered them all and said I've been
watching you this whole time this is why
and explained the anti-monitor to them
we need to stop him from consuming the
positive matter multiverse so within the
arrow verse there's only 52 or 53 earths
if you count earth X but during the
original crisis there were actually
infinite universes so I don't know if
we'd eventually worked up to some idea
like that but the monitor fought the
anti-monitor for eons till they both
went dormant for about a billion years
then somebody in the comics named pariah
conducted an experiment that
accidentally woke up the anti-monitor
and that's what kicked off crisis on
Infinite Earths so what they might be
doing with Jeremy Davies dr. destiny is
giving him a more pariah type role where
yeah he's doing something crazy in
Gotham they need to stop him but what he
does sort of tease up a much later event
that leads to their crisis on Infinite
Earths whatever the arrowverse TV
version of that event looks like
obviously it's not gonna be exactly like
the comics but it would definitely
explain why you would include Tyler
hoechlin Superman in every single
episode because if you're just taking
down criminals that have escaped from
Arkham Asylum then you don't really need
Superman for that the regular heroes are
just fine the other big thing that we
just found out is that Stephen Amell was
getting fitted for a mask like he was
during last year's crossover when he was
playing the earth X version of himself
in order to distinguish between the two
different versions he wore a black
costume obviously with a lot of
paraphernalia on it in a mask so what it
seems like is happening is is some of
the versions of the characters will be
alternate universe people so right now
during the first half of arrow season 7
Oliver is mostly stuck in prison but
obviously he's a big part of the
crossover so people are thinking that
the version of Oliver that we see during
the crossover will be from another
universe Stephen actually jumped onto
someone's tweet and did that like you
know curious emoji like maybe maybe I am
an alternate version of myself like he
was just messing with people he wasn't
trying to reveal anything but just keep
in mind that Elseworlds title the idea
that you're doing most of this story on
Batwoman separate universe earth and you
have a couple different versions of the
characters because I think they
partially want to explain the Batwoman
TV show if it actually ends up happening
is in a different continuity so she
doesn't run in
the earth one characters all the time
and they can do whatever story they want
they don't have to worry about what's
happening on the other TV shows just
like black lightning or just like the
Titans TV show kind of sitting in a
different universe not really in the
same continuity with the arrowverse
shows right now they're also in the
middle of filming the flash 100th
episode that's episode eight this season
because the crossover is gonna be
episode nine so no real spoilers or any
big details about that that they've
given away other than the fact that
they're going to be doing something that
will honor all of the comics history and
all the TV shows history so I'm assuming
just a whole bunch of cameos from their
biggest characters John Wesley Shipp
actually liked my tweet about the
hundredth episode so I don't think
that's confirmation or anything but that
does make me think that he's definitely
a part of the episode which would make
sense it would be weird to do your
hundredth episode and not involve Jay
Garrick in some way but as for us
meeting the new version of reverse-flash
or a flash Museum like other big things
I've already made a predictions video
for the most likely things that they'll
do just expect them to have a little bit
of fun with it and do a bunch of
fanservice the same way that arrow did
with their hundredth episode which is
why they move the crossover around
because normally the crossover would be
episode 8 for all the shows fun fact
about the first appearance of the
monitor in the comics - the first time
he ever showed up in the background
watching the heroes was during a Teen
Titans versus brother blood arc which is
kind of what they're doing the first
season of the Titans TV show just a
reminder a New York Comic Con is coming
up hopefully they'll drop some new
trailers the flash episode 1 is dropping
in two weeks and the week after that
most of the other shows come back I'll
remind everybody when I post new trailer
videos for that stuff but leave all your
requests in the comments below and leave
all of your monitor crisis on Infinite
Earths theories in the comments
congratulations Willie Rodriguez you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for that video of spider-man
in the new black costume in spider-man
far from home and click here for that
new Titans trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you